hey he's not set he ships a guy out and
he's not set for even half a second oh
we're on that you're not on it you're
not you're on it at
all yeah on the far
side you need something down there coach
maybe I was maybe call to call timeout
yeah well we need you if you're going to
call look no no no no I get this every
week if you need a timeout come on down
and call it so I came down there I
didn't take it and I moved back okay I
mean come on fellas I saw it out the
corner of my eye I got to concentrate on
the snap okay and I would have told you
if I needed it but I wanted to see what
the formation was and it was a ke
playing the
game all right we'll work together all
right I mean I'm not going to get out
here and get in the way